[creator] okay so update I made some changes to r7 orbit itself not specifically this game
[creator] I was having some github issues there was requiring a lot of manual fixes and
[creator] like I want this to be like as autonomous as it can be I don't want to
[creator] to do all that manual stuff you feel me so got a bunch of stuff updated so like
[creator] now I have like this github thing so I can actually make sure everything I'm
[creator] working on here has everything from github like whenever I reopen r7 orbit
[creator] because before it wasn't showing everything that was in github so I
[creator] and fix just a few things with the game itself. I just played through it. It took 12 minutes.
[creator] I died to a black hole. So yeah, I just gave it a new prompt though. As I was playing,
[creator] I was just telling it things to fix. So we're going to see how this goes. I also have sound
[creator] fix in now that you're hearing that are not from
[creator] the game
[creator] uh...
[creator] we actually turned one down there
[creator] and some effects
[creator] excuse me i just worked
[creator] so it would go for it
[creator] uh...
[creator] some effects that you're hearing of these little like
[creator] so anytime the test finishes
[creator] it will let me know with
[creator] sound i can also
[creator] do
[creator] to to to
[agent_tts] Atlas needs you.
[creator] whenever orbit needs me will
[creator] make this noise then when an agent is done working
[creator] if agent hits a problem
[creator] and then if I'm away from my computer or
[creator] doom-scrolling on my phone then it will
[creator] remind me every five minutes so that's just something new
[creator] we're gonna turn the voice on actually so
[creator] everything here is done ahead push this to github all right so then it's done so
[creator] that github piece went away up the up there at the top let's just get an
[creator] update here can you give me the update on what each agent worked on and what's
[creator] finished and maybe yeah so everything should be ready now so it's telling me
[creator] what each agent did I also updated some of the actual agent names that are in
[creator] so they're more like space-related. So you have like Voyager, Quasar, Polaris, Laika,
[creator] Laika I think is how it's pronounced, was one of the dogs that I'm pretty sure the Russians
[creator] sent into space, which is kind of messed up, really messed up I would say, anyway. So here
[creator] is the update. So let me turn the sound back on. I also had it hide the mouse so it's no
[creator] longer in the way. This I think looks a lot better. I want the background to be back though.
[creator] It kind of looks just like we're under water or in a void somewhere. But you know it still
[creator] isn't bad. I do think it looks a lot better than how it looked before though. It also
[creator] have added gravity so larger planets and objects should pull the other ones in. I don't know how
[creator] well that's actually working. I feel like I can kind of feel it pulling me but I could be wrong.
[creator] Let's see if I just stop next to this one. I guess its gravity isn't strong enough.
[creator] We'll just keep playing through. But I will say this feels
[creator] very very very much like Drifter Star. Alright let's see if I go near this. Will this object
[creator] pull me in closer? It doesn't really seem like the gravity is working the way I intended
[creator] it. I also don't really like that you can see these like kind of spawning in as you
[creator] go. They should be spawned off the screen. As you can see like they just keep spawning
[creator] let's go check that out was that over here it just it looks so good this is
[creator] all in the browser very impressed all right then I had to add images you could
[creator] actually see what you're gonna evolve into they're a little pixelated but it's
[creator] fine hmm let's do let's do this one since it
[creator] absorbs more and one thing actually while this is still put up we need some
[creator] stars in the background still it sort of just feels like we're in a void or like
[creator] underwater we need some sort of background still need stars we'll just
[creator] send that off I'm sure I'm gonna have to prove of some things so alright this
[creator] ones starting back up now backgrounds to empty
[creator] uh... so this was the agent those
[creator] charge of uh... simplifying the background that asked for before
[creator] uh... because whenever i remove the outlines of everything
[creator] whenever you get really big you're not going to have to see
[creator] a lot of these smaller
[creator] asteroids and planets and you'll eventually see what i mean
[creator] we turn the wind back up here
[creator] While this is working, I'm actually gonna go back full screen.
[creator] Another thing I wanna do is in Drifter Star,
[creator] you can actually kinda bang into these bigger asteroids
[creator] and break pieces off of them and capture those pieces.
[creator] That's something I wanna add to this.
[creator] Because right now, unless, like that right there,
[creator] I should've been able to break pieces off.
[creator] Maybe I am, but it just doesn't have a visual for that.
[creator] But regardless, that's something I wanna add
[creator] and just especially the gravity like these pieces should
[creator] like since I'm much larger they should be feeling the gravity
[creator] of what I am. Polaris is done which means
[agent_tts] This is done.
[creator] we should have a nicer background
[creator] brought back the stars in both renders
[creator] 2D and 3D or no the 2D hasn't been
[creator] viewed which is okay I only really care about the 3D right now
[creator] I'm still has a 2d fallback though oh that's maybe if I refresh this gonna
[creator] suck I gotta restart now but Polaris finished I'm able to just refresh the
[creator] browser or does something need to rerun and open it in the browser for media
[creator] tests for media tests whatever I know there are stars back there even though
[creator] they don't really they don't really look like stars they don't really look like
[creator] stars to me they look like very far away planets like they don't have a glow to
[creator] them
[creator] still doesn't quite like space
[creator] those more like little
[creator] flat speckles
[creator] so yeah this is the game so far i'm not going to keep recording just because
[creator] uh... there's no need for me to record this entire
[creator] process
[creator] so i will be back